florida has joined a growing list of
states that want abortion laws to be
more restrictive florida governor ron
desantis signed a bill into law
yesterday banning abortions after 15
weeks of pregnancy there are no
exemptions for rape incest or human
trafficking it comes as the supreme
court is set to review and potentially
overturn roe v wade the landmark 1973
decision that prevents states from
banning abortion jan crawford covers the
supreme court for us
jan good morning
good morning vlad you know we're seeing
this kind of wave of legislation because
if the court does overturn roe versus
way this summer like many people expect
then each state is going to get to
decide whether or not it's going to
allow access to abortion 23 states now
have laws that would restrict or ban
abortion if roe is overturned florida's
law for example it bans abortions after
15 weeks that's modeled after that
mississippi law now before the supreme
court and we're seeing other
republican-led states do the same thing
kentucky has cleared the way for its
15-week ban ass says arizona and west
virginia is among those considering it
and then you see these states passing
even more restrictive laws like oklahoma
that would make a performing an abortion
there a felony now on the flip side
there's the democratic states 16 states
and the district of columbia now protect
the right to an abortion and other blue
states are pushing that kind of
legislation or trying to go the route of
michigan where the governor she's suing
to get the state courts to say abortion
is protected there so you know we're not
uh expecting a decision from the supreme
court before the end of june we don't
know what this is going to rule but you
see these political battles in the
states they are already well underway
tony yeah the stakes could not be higher
jan thank you very much